when did the left become pro-war under
obama
under obama they didn't want to protest
him doing the exact same thing that they
protested bush doing
clinton was pro-war he was your father
with a smile i know
the left became pro-war after world war
ii because they want to prevent world
war three so they set up military bases
all over the earth
is that what it was yeah it's called the
uh well they call it eisenhower called
it the military industrial complex
right right right but what i'm saying is
i remember um
early 2010s people protest i remember
2000s
war is bad bush is bad war is bad then
obama gets in war is good now
yeah the people that were screaming
anti-war weren't left they were
like centrists the people that no i
far left was on so you know i'll tell
you what it was maybe they were
anti-bush too
no it was because i was i was i was i
was coming of age
during bush i was a teenager during bush
seeing all of these people claim to be
my ally and my friend saying war is bad
and i genuinely thought war was bad i'm
like i look at this stuff and this is
bad
and then as soon as obama got elected
i'm still standing there holding in the
sign saying war is bad and they go
uh we're going to get out of here and
i'm like but war is bad yeah but our guy
won so
that's all you ready the identity
anti-war guys because they'll go off
with their candidate when he wins and go
towards
a tribalist yeah people that worship
somebody
that's not identified it's it's the
anti-war concept that
it pervades it's forget who who's in
charge if they're going to war you got
to turn on them you got to stop the war
i think i think i think there are
instances where war is
unfortunate but good i think there are a
lot of instances where the us is
engaging in extremely stupid and bad war
that's just bad for us
but it's like you get some zealot who
wants to go and is mad about how someone
tried to kill his dad
and we end up in 20 years of war in the
middle east which
for what can we even talk about what we
gained from this and now all of a sudden
i'm sitting here like
donald trump hillary clinton i'm not
going to vote for a republican i'm not
hillary clinton she wants war
and then trump wins and now he's the guy
who hasn't started a war he's the guy
who's got historic peace agreements in
the middle east he's the guy who's
withdrawing our troops and i'm like
i still think war is bad hello left no
yeah
they're complaining about trump doing
this and you know what bothers me
is that even like i don't understand the
intercept
right glenn greenwald's outlet because
he's he's
complained about russiagate here here
why should it was nonsense he complains
about the media i
totally agree glenn he says he hears
criticism of trump and i'm like man
right right there you know
and then he says this is really great
that trump is ending more i'm like dude
glenn this is fantastic
so we're voting for trump now and he
goes no his outlet starts putting on all
trump is bad you know the far left is
good and i'm like
what yeah tribalism that's tribalism
it's it's
it's almost like glenn greenwald
is part of that left libertarian hacker
kind of thing that happened
and he is still too he's pulled into
this
weird new left that is either
identitarian or pro-war
establishments you know cabal
i think he's an identitarian glenn
greenwald he just doesn't like trump
i don't think he's an editarian he
doesn't he he criticizes the woke sjw
stuff
right but he dislikes trump so much
that's just that's just tribalist yeah
that's just orange man bad
maybe i'm conflating the the words
identitarian and tribalism i think
i think you're right i think there's
there's too many people on the left
who refuse to accept that they are
better off with trump than with joe
biden yeah
i don't care that's what i was saying
when you're talking about this phone
call with
with uh arthur if someone called me and
said that i'd be like
yeah f you click i don't care
i don't care if it's trump i don't care
if it's biden i don't care if it's
hillary
you tell me something that's good i'll
give you credit for it and if
i think you're doing a good enough job i
will vote for you for it the riots
flipped me
yeah i was like i remember last year i
was like i'm never going to vote for
this truck are you crazy it'll never
happen
nothing will ever change my [ __ ] i
know you're going to change your mind
and i'm like so where's the uh vote for
trump box is it said i'm gonna press
this button right here
you said earlier you thought that some
wars are good yeah
like world war ii defense of wars
that's bad but we have to do it right if
we get invaded which we've never been
invaded um well maybe like
if you go way back and talk about like
the territories and stuff
you know we've had conflict in our in
our own ground but in modern history all
of the conflicts we fought have been
going
other places and it's usually been
like we've had a lot of failures the u.s
has had a lot of stupid failures
korea vietnam i wouldn't necessarily say
korea was a failure
i'm actually kind of happy the u.s went
to queers my family
i probably wouldn't be here if the u.s
didn't intervene but it still
split the country in half vietnam was a
disaster and the gulf of tonkin was
complete bs what got us into the war was
complete bs afghanistan and iraq
complete disasters
and all the other stupid you know
incursion excursions that we do
in south and central america america
does a lot of really dumb things for a
lot of really dumb reasons
but we world war two we i understand
world war ii is like
i mean look right now we're look here's
one of the most difficult questions
we're looking at china china's got
concentration camps man
they're harvesting organs the things
they're doing to these people is is what
nightmares are made of
then they've got we got the oppression
in hong kong as well and they're
expanding
they're doing uh you know strike strike
groups going through the straight south
south china sea past taiwan and there's
fears that they're going to try and
seize taiwan
they claim taiwan is part of china
taiwan says otherwise this is going to
be a major conflict
what do we do i'm anti-intervention
always
even if it's a million people having
their organs harvested
always see for me i wouldn't say i'm
absolutely against intervention
but i'm when it comes to intervention
leaning away from it but we'll entertain
it
if there's an atrocity happening even
when we've went into war
with the best intentions um there's
always unintended consequences
i mean look at what happened with libya
we've went in there we
destabilized a whole bunch of things and
now they have open air slave markets
i know that's like we even if we're
doing something
and selling it to the public as as
good there's always going to be a
drawback and i
i firmly believe in only engaging in war
if the us
is directly threatened or if it's in our
national interest in a way that you know
there's no other option
do should we have intervened in world
war two no i don't think so
and i don't think we should have entered
world war one and i think that world war
ii wouldn't have happened without world
war one
that's an interesting point because i
was talking to michael malus about this
and i had a very generic ignorant view
of world war one and i need to do my
homework on it
but he mentioned it was a war of
alliances yeah world war ii
was clear-cut like this what what the
what nazi germany was doing was just
like
evil basic oh yeah we didn't even enter
world war ii to stop the holocaust
it people didn't even know about the
stuff that was happening
the debate here was about was america
first people and
like there was actually america first
committee back then
um it disbanded right when pearl harbor
was attacked but
the argument was about whether or not we
should be engaging in european conflict
and whether or not we should be helping
england it had nothing to do
with stopping atrocities because nobody
knew and a lot of this didn't start
until later
so sure um it that's not why
we entered world war ii we entered world
war ii to help
england but actually sorry
technically we entered because pearl
harbor got attacked but they had been
pushing for it because well i think it's
fair to point out we got attacked by
japan
and then sent soldiers to europe right
but i mean hindsight
being 2020 and i think that's not
necessarily the best point
i think it ended up being good yeah
we ended what they were doing but now we
know what china is doing so i'm not
saying we should
have an intervention in china or
anything like that right i'm just saying
like
not i think absolutism is is dangerous
like to reject all war all the time
i think i i support defending our our
country i support defending our borders
i support
if there's something that's in our
national interest that is
unavoidable i support it in that case
and i i'm not going to sit here and say
that it was bad to
to stop nazi germany but i do think that
there are consequences of that
and i think that you know look at
dresden look at what happened or
yeah look at what happened all over
germany and how many people died and how
many of our people died for something
that had nothing to do with us
and they were killing a lot of people so
a lot of people ended up living because
we came out right
and i i fully agree with that it's just
there are
there are consequences to these things
and now because
of world war ii and not being successful
they argue this for every intervention
they say well what would you have wanted
hitler to win
would you want to would you want to be
speaking german right now
and so they've used this forever to
justify
everything that's come later and so a
lot of people have died because of it
i agree that's just my opinion i agree i
think there's been a lot of mistakes
where
the us has intervened and failed and
then world war ii
becomes the like key example of why it's
good because
that was really important that that
ended you know that we shut those people
down
the challenge now is like how do we deal
with china i mean look
i don't believe the united states of the
world are the world's police but i do
have a concern
that we're watching china arm up we're
watching them
abuse their neighbors potential war with
india could happen
and india is an ally of ours and so
we're we're seeing the atrocities they
commit
we're seeing them defy international law
and norms
setting up military bases on the south
china sea atolls and things like that
or the pacific atolls they're spreading
encroaching and giving
becoming more and more powerful i don't
bel i don't i don't like the idea of
just intervention we're going to we
don't like what they're doing they may
threaten us preemptive war that's a
terrible idea
what if we s the other side of that coin
is if we sit back while they expand in
south america
and africa gaining resources and buying
out all these countries eventually
you'll be living in authoritarian
communists and china is an interesting
case because i think
they own farmland in the u.s that i
think is equal to the size of ohio
my boyfriend brett mcdonald has wrote
about this extensively
but they they are buying a lot of land
here and i
i don't agree with that either and i
think china is an interesting case
and there is you know there there are
arguments to be made
for intervening there but when you're
talking about intervention broadly
you have to think about why you care
about these atrocities
because there's atrocities all over the
world at any given time
i mean look what hap look look at yemen
but they don't want you to care about
yemen they want you to care about
venezuela why is that and so
they pick and choose the atrocities that
they want to highlight and the ones that
we need to save people from
and there's always another motive for it
and i guarantee that
the the weapons manufacturers are not
concerned about the fact that people
are starving that's not why they want to
go there so yeah we've had drone strikes
in yemen we had obama killing americans
uh uh abdulrahman al-awlaki i believe
was in yemen killing an american
citizen without charge or trial and then
saying oopsie well luke got that great
video he confronted his press secretary
and
we are changing yeah he was like um any
comments about the fact that you guys
killed an american teenager
and i think it was his press secretary
was like he should have had a different
father
better dad a better [ __ ] better dad is
that why he was killed
yeah in my opinion maybe it's a little
bit conspiratorial but i kind of feel
like if those aren't familiar there's a
man named anwar al-awlaki he was
preaching jihad against the u.s
obama drone striked him and then two
weeks later i think it was
in a country we were not at war with
they drone-striked a civilian restaurant
killing his year old son who i believe
was born in like boulder colorado yeah
it was colorado
that sounds to me like obama saying we
will kill your children
if you if you f with us the official
story was we're targeting someone else
it was a mistake
the question then is why were we
targeting someone at a civilian
restaurant in a country we are not at
war with
because they don't care yeah it's like a
kid with a magnifying glass from above
just dropping a bomb on a restaurant
and that stuff causes harm to america
it's with cia called it blowback that we
like could you imagine
you you blow up a restaurant those
there's gonna be people there like some
dad's gonna watch his he's gonna he's
gonna be across the street it's gonna be
movie-esque
and he's gonna see a restaurant get
blown up and he's gonna they're gonna
see the drone they're gonna be panicking
his kid's gonna be gone
and that guy is gonna become radicalized
in an instant and he's gonna do
everything in his power against
us because somebody made a mistake to to
go
with the establishment narrative i i
can't claim otherwise i have no evidence
but then all of a sudden you end up with
terror conflict and refugees people
fleeing these countries their homes
destroyed
and that creates even more conflict and
you know what they're people who strive
on this stuff thrive on this stuff
they love it they profit off of it and
the rest of us suffer because of it
so anyway well i don't that's why
wikileaks is so important
i don't i'm not saying they show you the
true cost of war
and then you can make an informed
decision as a public but to be fair
i mean with wikileaks how often they
have they released documents on china
i'm not actually sure but they've
released a lot of documents that
don't get as much exposure as us stuff
for sure
i mean they've they've released tons of
files on even russia people are always
like how come they've never done
anything on russia and
there are cables on russia like go on
their website and search you'll find
anything there
i think there was like one point where
someone asked julian that or something
and he was like these files are already
public
they're like why didn't you release
these files they were public someone
sent us files that were already public
so we ignored it like
you know and i think uh julian probably
does what he thinks
uh or he was i don't know what he's what
his capacity is now because of what's
happening to him
but he probably focused on what he
thought was the most important and i'm
not saying you have to agree with with
you know with what he thinks is
important but
i will i will argue that one of the
views of
one of the arguments against wikileaks
is that he was consistently
targeting the us and if you're only
hitting us
over and over and over again it's going
to be helping our adversaries
that's not true though they just don't
get as much coverage
right you know he's released all kinds
of things from all
all the different nations all over the
country but we're not going to
talk about those cables as much here i
mean you can pull up wikileaks right now
and type in any nation and you're
probably going to find
thousands of documents yeah um it's
it just depends what our media wants to
cover and
our media isn't interested in things
that are anti-war
or things that you know make certain
governments look bad
so you know i think that people are
blaming
julian for the failings of the media
when on that argument
definitely because the new york times
got us into the wars
and and other big mainstream outlets
they lied to us
man it's funny how a lot of my political
views were shaped by growing up
in during this time and it's kind of
crazy when i think about how much i
don't know from even 10 years before i
was born
like the context of how the media
operated i wonder if i was 10 years
older and i saw the flip how it's like
pro-war or democrat then anti-war
under bush and then pro-war under obama
again i would have been
sort of insulated from seeing you know
from believing that the democrats had my
best interest
that they really thought war was bad and
then i learned the hard way i love it
when i voted for obama in 2008
i'm like smiling with my friends and i
was like you know i was a skateboarder i
was kind of punk
i was kind of getting moving a little
bit away from the far left and then
people were telling me like dude obama's
not one of these establishment people
he's like
an up-and-coming dude he's a regular guy
and i'm like cool and i went and i'm
like yeah
obama and then the first thing obama
does when he gets inaugurated
i think it was an air strike on a
village killing women and children and i
was like ah
wait a minute what what you told me that
was bad they're like no no no it's good
it's good it's like what do you mean
it's good
you told me nonstop it was bad i voted
for this guy these are hope and change
drones
oh that's right the drone the missile
said hope and the the
the the reaper said uh help
and the hellfire said uh change when um
hope and change blow up those women and
children when they got in they did that
let's move campaign i don't know if you
guys remember michelle obama had a
lesbian
campaign and it was originally about
cutting sugar out of your diet
and the sugar industry did not like that
so they got their fingers in there and
then switched it and made it into an
exercise campaign
that sugar industry is insidious man
it's one of the most addictive drugs
sugar and it's like the tobacco industry
of the 70s people don't realize selling
sugar to kids
all war all conflict all conspiracy
sugar industry big sugar i was wondering
like a guy selling candy canes with
shifty eyes you know there's this
military-industrial complex that they
built after world war
ii um it was like the british and the
english and the french just wanted to
prevent world war iii i wonder if
there's a chinese military-industrial
complex that we don't hear anything
about
oh yeah or if it's all one complex do
you know the name of the chinese
state like spy agency no they just call
it beijing
yeah yeah what was that that was that
was in a show someone was talking about
it but it's a good point
like the cia the kgb or what is what is
the russian thing now
fsb i think yeah and they just say
beijing i think it's like a mission
impossible movie or something
unless there actually is a name i know
they have like this this like they call
it the state military
ministry of like service or something
like that but yeah there definitely is
uh trump was talking about this not not
you gotta admit war is bad
but don't you love trump's blunt honesty
on this stuff
because one of my all-time favorite
things trump has ever done was when he
walked up to the the reporters
and they're like what's going on with
this weapon seal oh it's really great
we're giving all of these weapons to
saudi arabia we're gonna make a lot of
money you know and then all the anti-war
people were like
i was horrified he just but he just said
it yeah he just
came out and admitted war profiteering
essentially
and uh i'm like but he also calls out
the military
industrial complex like he's done it
twice now and like
so when he's talking about syria and
he's like i you know what i love i think
he does it on purpose
to to get at them trump wanted to
withdraw from syria yeah and they all
started complaining oh no oh no the oil
the oil
so trump left soldiers in and now he's
just like we're withdrawing our troops
from syria
but we're keeping the oil so the
soldiers are still there to guard the
oil that's what we're doing
but we're getting i think he's saying it
specifically as like uh that's what the
us is doing
like that's that's what they wanted they
complained when he wanted to get our
troops out and that's what we're there
for
uh the oil and the hair with the poppy
seeds basically in afghanistan
we can't grow poppy here i don't know
lemon papaya muffins are fantastic
they're delicious yeah other than oil
and poppy seeds i don't know why we're
over there
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 p.m so come
back to check us out when
we go live don't forget to subscribe hit
the like button
hit the notification bell and we are
also available on all podcast platforms
for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time